okay where are we we're in part for so
so far we've we know where it started we
know what happens after 10 years and we
know where it's going to end in theory
who knows why they suddenly magically
stop decreasing after 150 but whatever
here's the way they've set it out now I
want to say two things number one you
didn't have to solve this as an
inequality you can see why they've
solved it as a new collar though right
like look at the ledge language of the
question it says when the population
falls below 300 so therefore any value
less than 200 that's fine of course they
actually want a specific point in time
so there's nothing wrong with doing
something like this right instead of
solving 4 p's less than 200 just solve
for web p is 200 i wouldn't be surprised
if most of you did this one of the
reasons why that's advantageous is
because equations much less I see then
inequalities you have to worry about a
direction of the inequality and so on
but then of course what you got to do
from that is once you find that value
right where that's satisfied then you
have to interpret that result
accordingly so you have to make a
statement right guess you're lost my
copy T equals 30 5.83 because that's not
like it is more than that to the
question right that's the first thing i
want to say if you set it up as an
equation rather than isn't inequality
then you've got to do that secondly
we've actually said this and here are
the two bucks by the way there's not
really anything for these initial lines
like they're very easy to get your two
marks are for sorry manipulating to make
tea the subject so you've got your your
exponential your log there and then your
second final mark was to actually find
out what that time what um so I'm going
to get to that so when I say one mark is
on stating the time okay here if you end
it on t is greater than 30 5.83 think
you've answered the question okay but if
you end it on T equals 30 5.83 you have
not right because when the population
falls below 200 there's a whole range of
times where the population has fallen
below 200 right okay now again there's
no accuracy provided on
the question I don't believe so I'm not
going to worry about rounding at the
moment in this case you got lucky
because the normal way of rounding is
going to be the correct way around in
this case you've gotta round up because
if you went down suppose it was thirty
five point two years and you went down
to 35 years which is the nearest number
what will the population be well will be
more than 200 at that point right it
still has a dip down luckily for you
here it didn't matter because whichever
way you approximately fine but the thing
I actually want to make that off was
this guy skipped over when you translate
from this exponential equation right
down to this equation which is on the
log equation okay we can kind of do this
by definition yeah like for example if i
said to you two cubed equals eight then
you could write the log equation off of
this instead of the exponential equation
as log base two of sorry log base two of
ya eight equals three right now the
thing with that is it's an equation so
you can write the three left so you can
write the threat right does it matter
but the way this has been set up it's an
inequality so does bow try taking logs
of both sides sort of rescues you from
this problem because think about what
this um this top line let me put it in a
new color for you think about what this
top line means this means you've got a
number on the left and it's smaller than
the number on the right yeah so if you
take logs of both sides the log of a
small number will be smaller than the
longer than big double room logs are
back when we introduce it right logs
that are amount of time to grow to a
certain amount of certain sized right
I'll be able to grow to a smaller size
faster right it's a smaller amount of
time this is a big amount right so if
you take logs of both sides rather than
jumping straight to oh I can interpret
this is in as a long equation you'll
preserve the direction of the inequality
okay so that was the first question any
queries
fine yep yeah that's right if you have
this thing here that kind of says I
understand what this equals sign means I
understand that solving that just like
if you were solving you know if you saw
me something like this right right you
solving something like that and there's
nothing wrong with saying okay I were to
find the boundary point and I'll do that
by solving the equation that gives me
the boundary point and then you're gonna
have to obviously answer with and
inequality because you've got to return
back to the original question and it's
exactly the same deal with this
exponential growth then decay okay cool
let's move on to number two which I
think was decidedly more straightforward
so I'm just going to go ahead and tell
you where the marks are part 1 that's
the that's the case you've seen many
many times so all you have to do is
differentiate hope you all got that part
too there are three bucks and that's
because there are three things you
needed to evaluate you had to find a to
find K that you had to find K to find
out and then you found him okay so yeah
absolutely underneath yeah
don't know I don't I always leave it
exact I don't think I ever approximate
wait what oh you did something oh okay I
see what you did alright Ricky arrow all
right at least you got two out of three
on that probably so can I can I say I've
said this many times on the exponential
growth in K and each of these talking
about what happens to Tori so what
happens down here the thing about rates
of change in X spiritual growth and
decay is that the differentiation and
even the integration where it required
is not difficult it's the exact opposite
for the extension to stood of extension
to integration where it's like here's
the hardest integral you can probably
possibly have this all the calculus is
easy what's hard is arranging them
interpreting them start actually giving
you the right equation so you get the
answer out and get a value that's
correct okay so a K&N there are your
three bucks that was a civil one so shut
up LOL looks good question 3 now no
marks but bonus points if you drew that
tank with what coming out of it like I
always do I here we go part 2 this is
the first time is too much so I'll just
explain where the marks go just like
before in question 1 you're given a
volume expression as a function of time
but you don't have a derivative so if
you want to rate you have to find the
derivative so that's the first mark
differentiate right the second mark is
there just to say well at time 20 at T
equals 20 tell me what the rate of
change is so its trading 80 meters per
minute or negative 8 is negative 8 is ok
but I keep on saying don't don't skip
guys don't skip on the sentence oh sure
two and a half thousand meters ok now
part 3 was he interesting it was
probably surprisingly interesting and
there are a few ways to go about this
but I think this is probably most
efficient way the question says at what
time does the model predict that the
water would drain from the tank at its
fastest rate now when you hear that word
fastest you should be thinking oh this
is a maximization problem
right what am I trying to maximize I'm
trying to maximize devient dt right so
if you want to maximize the derivative
if you've gotta climb one level of
differentiation down so that's why
they've gone to the second derivative
it's an easy function to differentiate
just go for it you get a constant so
what does that mean it means it's always
increasing going from a really negative
dub are progressively going on 20 way of
course it should right because it starts
trading out really fast it as a X down
to the bottom it slows down right air
pressure by Kofi so therefore though for
two marks you can't just like know that
I can't just that oh it's gonna be
fastest at the beginning okay you've got
to justify there are no stationary point
to you you do that by finding the second
derivative right on the basis of that
that means that the maximum flow rate
has to happen at an end point right time
equals 0 x equals 60 it's got to be one
of those so you just test them I'll look
at your individual solutions later oh
I'm happy to look at able individual
solutions afterwards yeah question yeah
okay so if if you have a graphical
solution or good with a graphical
solution with one condition your graph
has to be good it has to be good enough
to argue off right so if your graph is
like some you know some rotten those are
the rough things if you're doing
something rough at your like I roughly
looks like that it's not sufficient if
you want to make a graphical argument
your autograph has to be a really good I
think this is kind of quick up but
anyhow the graph is fine so then what
the fastest air twice minus 120 and
that's time 0 okay last question now
remember I said that this was done very
poorly okay you can see some stats over
there on the right hand side what's
going on some people many people
actually thought oh it's a flow rate
better differentiate right but of course
you don't have to because
this is this is the opposite of those
earlier questions where you get give it
a volume expression here you're already
given the derivative that's what that T
plus sorry two plus T squared on T plus
white is right so all you needed to do
was take the difference um now just
quickly right this is a part 1 they
didn't say handsaw otherwise in part 2
but when there's a part 1 2 3 it's
always implied that's why it's a part 1
2 3 so when you look at this thing and
you're like I don't want to integrate
that yeah yeah you don't have to
integrate that because in part one you
showed that the difference was t so use
that and then it becomes quite trivial
okay